turning now to the war in ukraine the
russian assault is getting more violent
by the day and many civilians are dying
five people were killed yesterday when a
tv tower was bombed in ukraine's capital
city the attack also damaged the
holocaust memorial where jews killed by
nazi occupiers are buried ukraine's
president called the strike undisguised
terror charlie dagda is in the capital
keefe charlie good morning
good morning to you nate the bombardment
of major cities has intensified
including a number of explosions and
missile strikes here in the capital in
kharkiv more heavy fighting today after
russian paratroopers landed in that city
firefighters battle blaze in the
aftermath of a suspected russian
airstrike in a desperate search for
survivors just 80 miles west of the
capital
the mayor said the target was a
residential building near a hospital at
least four people have died including a
young child
ukrainian forces are today battling a
russian invasion on multiple fronts in
the south russians have launched
sweeping offensives on strategic port
cities along the black sea kurzan is now
under control of russian troops
according to local officials the largest
city yet to fall
and in mariopol these mothers and their
newborns were forced to move to an
improvised bomb shelter in the basement
of the city's maternity hospital
in the east the ferocious assault on
kharkiv ukraine's heavily populated
second city continues
described by president zielinski as a
war crime residential neighborhoods
destroyed
families displaced but the ukrainian
military says what president putin
really wants is to seize the capital
itself
officials say five people were killed in
a russian missile attack targeting a
television transmission tower near
central keeve
this might just be the beginning
russia's defense ministry warned that
troops would be attacking what they said
was the country's intelligence
infrastructure and warned residents to
leave
the 40-mile convoy of russian tanks and
other military vehicles snaking toward
the capital seems to have stopped in its
tracks
and a second military convoy has been
seen moving in on the capital from the
east a u.s official tells cbs news the
siege may just be a matter of time a
current assessment predicts russian
forces could isolate the capital in a
week and take it over 30 days after that
standing in their way ukrainian soldiers
and ordinary citizens
digging in defiant and determined to
stop the russian advance whatever the
cost
in addition to the pressure piling on
here president putin is facing a
different kind of battle at home apple
has stopped selling iphones and other
products saying it's deeply concerned
about the invasion of ukraine exxon
mobil says it's preparing to shut down
production and investment in development
projects ford motor companies suspending
joint venture operations in russia among
the growing number of major companies
now pulling back from doing business
with russia tony
each and every one of those a new brick
in the wall but so far none of it's
strong enough to stop putin's advance
charlie dagger to force charlie thank
you very much